how's it going everyone and welcome to
wait that was wrong
my name is Peter Beth and welcome to
Friday would be and bang
okay sorry I thought that I didn't have
making funny faces first of all I'm
really glad that a lot of you liked the
whole I don't get dark on me the whole
competition thingy I am definitely gonna
do it again since it was successful and
after all
Friday Fran it would appear to pop it's
for you guys my subscribers so I thought
that in the next week I'll I'll let you
guys do the frying pan and just what you
have to do is leave a video response to
this video where you do whatever you
like just say Friday would be too bad
and do something with your eyes I don't
know even what I'm doing and I'll pick
the winner and it will be the intro for
the next it's waiting already be
creative be funny do whatever I mean you
could do I mean I'm not saying my
production it's pretty I what am I
talking about
anyway do you like people kind of forgot
what I was doing that I could be like
Wednesday's with PewDiePie his beard or
something I could just sit like here ah
for entire entire video by stroking my
beard broken mumble and anyway this is
my last night in Italy I'm like super
sad to leave I'm going back to Sweden
tomorrow and I'll keep on recording from
then I done the reason why I recorded
fatal frame was because I was going away
and I wanted something to upload and
people were like I'm not referring I'm
like do you hear what I'm saying I know
what I'm saying but it it doesn't come
out very well I know what I'm writing
I'm writing helping itch to feet day so
yeah I think I'm here because I don't
know what I'm talking about
don't forget like you do a video
response why not it could be fun
I want many many submissions for this
yes so it's Friday you're home you have
nothing better to do and watch me so why
not I'll promise all them I'll put more
effort into these I once I get back to
Sweden and I'm I know it's it's
difficult and recording these two my
girlfriend's computer and all that so
but anyway it's been three minutes in or
three seconds I only 23 minutes okay I
have the end of that [ __ ] I overdid it
this is still running